hey youtubers it's Charlie hopefully
you've all had a chance to see the
Deadpool test footage that was leaked
ahead of Comic Con what it was was just
some test footage it wasn't an official
trailer from Fox someone leaked it just
trying to drum up some interest in the
movie Fox was trying to get a Deadpool
movie going back in 2011 so the footage
that you saw was from 2011 it was just
released now so this video is gonna be a
breakdown of the footage and what's
happening with the project right now a
couple of big-name people are actually
running an experiment right now on
Twitter also quick heads up to Irish of
'old a few my videos this weekend so
just check my facebook for an update on
that or Twitter links for that at the
bottom of the description and in case
you're finding me for the first time I
do DC and Marvel videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything so
let's start talking about that footage
the real story is that blur Studios the
people that actually made the footage
leaked it to the Internet ahead of Comic
Con it was done without Fox's knowledge
Fox had nothing to do with it and right
after they posted it it was taken down
then people reapplied at it
then it got taken down again rinse
repeat you get the idea it's like the
Hydra model cut off one head to grow in
its place it wasn't part of any kind of
panel they were doing it was just the
blur people trying to drum up interest
at Fox trying to show them that people
were interested in a Deadpool movie even
though the test footage is from way back
in 2011 Fox still has not greenlit the
movie yet the trailer itself features
Ryan Reynolds voicing the character and
presumably he's still down to play the
role if the movie ever does end up
happening here's a quick breakdown of
what's going on with the movie itself
there is a finished script it was
written by Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick
Ryan Reynolds along with all the other
people that read it said it was great so
way up at the top Lauren Shuler Donner
and Simon Kinberg the producers on the
movie they're on board with the idea but
the other people at Fox the people that
actually write the checks don't really
want to make an r-rated comic book movie
I think we can all agree that a Deadpool
movie would have to be hard are in order
to be taken seriously the source
material isn't like anything we've seen
recently and that's part of the reason
why Fox is afraid to make one for
example guardians of the galaxy super
successful movie about a big group of
saving the galaxy Deadpool on
the other hand is a cold-blooded killer
like it's in the name his body count
would have to be higher than a zombie
apocalypse movie in right now that comic
book movie culture is tuned for
family-friendly stories the closest
example of a hard-r movie like Deadpool
would be is Punisher war zone
and everybody kind of remembers that
movie it was fairly infamous for being
really really bad anytime anyone walks
into fox and asks for 70 million dollars
to make an r-rated comic book movie all
they have to do is point at punisher and
say it's not gonna work nobody wants to
make a movie that isn't guaranteed to
earn a billion dollars so the big
question is is how do you make a
Deadpool movie that earns a billion
dollars there are a couple of options
mostly just tuned it down to pg-13 so
you can market it to a bigger audience
also for markets like China have very
strict rules about violence in films if
you can get a movie released in China
that's like an extra hundred million
dollars you could potentially make
that's why transformers 4 had so many
Chinese elements in the movie because
there were a bunch of Chinese companies
backing the film and because they wanted
the government to release it the
government their control which movies
get released so most studios really want
to get their movies released in China
just because potentially it's an extra
billion people that will buy tickets to
your movie so moving on to marketing
there's some interesting stuff going on
on social media now with the people
behind the film they're trying to draw
up some interests right now on Twitter
Rhett Reese the guy that actually wrote
the script is asking fans to retweet a
specific tweet of his if they'll go see
or buy tickets for r-rated Deadpool
movie even Rob Liefeld the artist on the
Deadpool comic jumped on board it just
started but I'll actually post a link in
the description in case you guys want to
participate Rhys is just asking you to
retweet his tweet as a way to show Fox
that people are really interested and
will buy tickets for an r-rated Deadpool
movie so I know a lot of you guys are
just asking why don't they just
kick-start the film why don't fans just
crowd fund it the reason they can't do
that is because Fox owns the rights so
the only way that filmmakers could
kickstart a Deadpool movie would be if
Fox said ok and they have not so thus no
Kickstarter I have not read the script
which apparently is pretty good but here
are some of my picks for stories I think
they should do at the top is Joe Kelly's
run on Deadpool it's collected in an
omnibus if you guys haven't read it his
run started in 1997 he's basically the
guy that gave Deadpool all the signature
character traits that you see in the
current comics start to finish it is one
of the best collections of Deadpool
stories ever in fact most of the time
when you see people posting Deadpool
pictures on the internet they're using
pictures from his run after that there's
Deadpool's time on x-force it's Rick
Remender run
uncanny x-force it's collected in an
omnibus - in case you guys want to read
it all it started in 2010 with uncanny
x-force number one and went through
issue 35 there actually is an x-force
movie in development at Fox which is
probably gonna get made so even if
Deadpool doesn't get his own solo movie
maybe he could be part of the x-force
movie even if he's not part of the team
he could just have a cameo in the movie
like he did in Wolverine Origins usually
when people make a new team-based
comic-book movie they keep it pretty
simple like x-men started with a small
cast and then expanded so I'm not
expecting Fox to Jam Deadpool into their
first x-force movie but he could always
have a small cameo and that would be a
good way to drum up interest for another
Deadpool movie after those two runs I
feel like Merc with a mouth would be the
next place to go first story Deadpool in
the Savage Land it just sounds like so
much fun
picture him walking around with his
decaying severed head that he talks to
that might be a little much to expect
from a movie but I'd love to see them
include the talking head as an easter
egg they did kind of do it in the
Wolverine Origins movie but it's not
about him just talking to the head the
head would have to look like he's been
carrying it around all year like super
gross but not quite a skeleton head but
the really important thing is obviously
the actor so Ryan Reynolds is the last
one to play the role do you guys want to
see him come back I feel like his career
has hit a bit of a speed bump so it
seems like this is the kind of project
that he would jump on board with really
quickly usually high-profile movies like
this are an express train to rebooting
someone's career here's a quick list of
other people I think would make great
Deadpool actors first up is Zachary
Quinto I feel like he did a great job of
playing a crazy supervillain on heroes
even though that show kind of lost some
steam Jonathan Rhys Meyers is another
person that's great at playing crazy
people I don't picture Deadpool with a
British accent and if you did see him on
the first season of Dracula it actually
got cancelled he had the worst fake
American accent so they'd have to tune
it just a little bit but he's great
actor Jeremy Renner would be amazing if
he weren't already Hawkeye interesting
side note though there was actually an
awesome Deadpool vs. Hawkeye storyline
in the comics during the Dark Reign
period Sam Worthington I feel would be
another great pick he has the right
physique but he would have to go way
over the top most of his acting is
pretty reserved mostly tough-guy acting
I could maybe get on board with Tom
Hardy I'm looking forward to seeing him
in Mad Max fury road but I feel like
he'd have a harder time selling the
comedic aspects of Deadpool but I think
he could do it but let me know if they
decide to go with a different actor who
you want to see them cast as Deadpool as
of right now I don't think we're
actually gonna see at that pool movie
till after x-force and that movie won't
get made till after x-men apocalypse and
probably the next Wolverine solo movie
they're actually working on an old man
Logan movie for Hugh Jackman so expect
them to prioritize that I feel like
those movies are big reason why Fox
isn't really rushing into Deadpool just
because they feel like they have some
safe bets like they feel like they know
how to make x-men and Wolverine movies
they have the formula down and they have
guaranteed profits so they're not
scrambling for too many other new
franchises they're trying to figure out
Fantastic Four which can completely go
sideways so I think they're also kind of
waiting to see how that goes I know a
lot of you guys are really worried about
that new Fantastic Four movie I'm just
gonna wait till I see stuff from it to
do any videos in related news since all
you guys responded to my Twitter and
Facebook post this morning I'll be
posting a new Doctor Who and legend
decor and next I'll try to have all that
stuff up by Saturday morning but you
guys can always follow me on Twitter and
Facebook for updates there's links to
that at the bottom of the description
right now click here to get a breakdown
of all the DC movies coming after Batman
vs Superman they announced nine of them
there's a ton and click here to learn
all about guardians of the galaxy -
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives
you